just yesterday next js announced version
12 and it was even more impressive than
apple's new macbook announcements which
is pretty mind-blowing considering it's
just a free javascript framework they're
setting the bar really high for what a
full stack javascript framework is
expected to do like it now ships with a
rust compiler instead of javascript to
give you 5x faster builds you don't need
to know rest it just makes next faster
under the hood by replacing babel which
is important because big complex apps
tend to have slow build times and i've
already updated my full next.js course
to use version 12. and i'm seeing
significantly faster refresh and build
times that's pretty amazing but it's not
even close to being the coolest feature
in this release let's take a look at all
the new features in x12 and more
importantly why you would want to use
them if you're new here like and
subscribe and if you want to get really
good at next consider enrolling in my
full course grab a discount in the
description the first feature i want to
look at is middleware middleware is not
a new concept frameworks like express.js
use middleware to intercept an http
request and process it in some way
before it goes to your actual route
handler with something like next.js
though things are a little more
complicated on one hand you want your
website to be really fast and the best
way to make that happen is to cache
pre-built html pages on a cdn but when
you do that you lose the ability to make
your pages dynamic so on the other end
of the spectrum you have server side
rendering that uses a node server to
fetch data from a database or api when
the incoming request comes in but that
is slow and inefficient in a perfect
world though developers would have both
speed and dynamic content at the same
time and next is really leading the way
to make that happen resell the company
behind next has a product called edge
functions these are serverless functions
like aws lambda or google cloud
functions except they're deployed to the
edge like a cdn so your end users get
extremely fast execution with no cold
starts now here's where middleware comes
in in your project create a file called
underscore middleware in the pages
directory from inside it you can export
a function called middleware this
function will give you access to the
incoming request and allow you to modify
it and it will run before rendering
takes place for every page in the pages
directory you can also scope the
middleware to subdirectories if you only
want it to run on a subset of pages
what's awesome about middleware is that
it makes your code way more efficient
for example i may need to verify a user
authentication credential on every page
if the user is logged in we might want
to retrieve some data from a database
otherwise redirect to the login page
instead of importing that logic into
every page i can now just define it in
the middleware and it will run on every
page automatically but as an added bonus
when you go to deploy the middleware is
hosted on vercell edge functions instead
of having one centralized node server
your backend code is deployed to the
edge where it's very close to the end
user and therefore much faster that's
great for burcell but if you're worried
about vendor lock-in it provides a
standard build output that you can
deploy to any platform it's just going
to take a lot more work to configure now
let's move on to the next big feature in
x12 support for react concurrent mode
like suspense if you're not familiar
with suspense it's basically a component
that allows you to wait for asynchronous
data before rendering its children as of
today it's still experimental in react
but it's still used in production on
some websites like facebook however if
you try to use it in next it results in
errors because it doesn't play well on
the server in next 12 you can opt into
experimental concurrent features to get
these features working with server side
rendering it also supports react lazy to
dynamically import yes modules which can
reduce the size of your client-side
javascript bundle now this next feature
might be the one that i'm most excited
about react server components server
components allow you to natively render
html from a react component on the
server what's crazy about it though is
that it uses http streaming to
progressively render a web page on the
server that means if you need data for
one component and then another component
after that you don't have to wait for
one after the other it'll render the
first one then the next one then the
next one after that which really opens
up a whole new world of possibilities
when it comes to designing full stack
web applications with server components
you can stream html from an edge
function immediately and progressively
show updates as your data comes in and
next you can change a page or file name
to dot server.js to tell the framework
that it's a server component when this
component is rendered it requires zero
client-side javascript that means fewer
kilobytes for the end user to download
in addition you can fetch data directly
inside the component without having to
use functions like git static props or
get server-side props it's a really
ergonomic way to build an application
you use react patterns from start to
finish or server to client now you'll
likely want some interactive javascript
for the client so you can also import
regular client components as well and
they'll be rendered universally both on
the server and the client the
combination of server components and
middleware looks like a really awesome
way to build an app i'm actually
considering redesigning the entire
fireship site with these latest features
if you guys want to see that as a series
here on youtube make sure to let me know
in the comments to wrap things up
there's one more cool feature you'll
want to know about you can now import
modules using urls instead of npm this
works for javascript modules that you
would import from a cdn but you can also
use remote urls in your css or to import
images directly into your javascript
code overall next.js version 12 is a
total beast make sure you're subscribed
for more updates and if you're a pro
member stay tuned for more updates to
the full course thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one